[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de libre-échange
sur Public Sénat 30 minutes de
conversation avec celles et ceux qui
font avancer l'économie française votre
invité aujourd'hui c'est Olivier sechel
le directeur de la banque des
territoires bonjour merci d'être là avec
nous alors plus de 4 millions de
Français qui sont mal logés l'immobilier
neuf on le sait qui est en panne des
rénovations énergétiques qui sont trop
lentes cette crise du logement en France
qui sévit est-ce que c'est une bombe à
retardement c'est effectivement le
bombardement c'est c'est une situation
qui préoccupait énormément les Français
le logement c'est leur premier poste de
dépenses alors de ce côté là la banque a
des territoires elle a une sont très
importantes parce que vous savez la
banque des territoires c'est celle qui
finance le logement social le logement
social c'est plus de 5 millions de
logements en France et c'est celui qui
loge les plus démunis non seulement donc
on est le grand prêteur de ce secteur là
et on essaye d'en faire le plus possible
pour construire des logements sociaux
mais on est aussi un opérateur un
opérateur qui s'appelle CDC habitat qui
a décidé en pleine crise de logement de
racheter un certain nombre de logements
pour éviter que tous les logements mis
en construction par les promoteurs ne
trouvent pas preneur donc on a un rôle
très important dans cette crise qui est
un peu particulière en ce moment parce
que c'est à la fois une crise de la
demande et une crise de l'offre c'est
une crise de la demande parce que les
taux d'intérêt ont augmenté très
fortement les Français ont du mal
obtenir un prêt pour acheter un logement
et donc il y a ils ont du mal et ça
coûte plus cher c'est les deux à la fois
plus cher et de l'autre côté il y a
aussi une crise de l'offre parce que moi
qui passe mon temps à avoir des mers les
mers vous disent c'est de plus en plus
difficile d'accorder des de construire
donc comment on fait une fois qu'on a
posé ce diagnostic et très clair crise
de l'offre crise de la demande comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour rénover à la fois
plus de logements anciens construire
plus d'appartements plus de maisons et
j'ai envie de dire à des prix qui sont
décents à des prix qui sont abordables
alors la rénovation c'est une histoire
de de financement et dans le logement
social ça va assez bien on a rénové plus
de 160 000 logements sociaux et c'est un
bon rythme alors vous allez me dire
c'est facile parce que les bailleurs
sociaux c'est des pros du logement c'est
leur métier de rénover ils sont tout le
temps dans le bâtiment ils savent quels
sont les bons artisans quels sont les
bonnes technologies à mettre en oeuvre
ou à réinitialisation performante
ce qui est plus difficile c'est un petit
peu j'ai envie de dire comme vous et moi
quand on a un logement par performant
comment est-ce qu'on s'y retrouve pour
faire une rénovation thermique sans
avoir un reste à charge qui soit trop
important déjà même avant le reste à
charge le problème c'est que vous allez
voir en disant vous allez voir un
chauffagiste qui va vous dire voilà faut
prendre une chaudière à gaz et puis vous
allez voir un autre chauffagiste il dit
non c'est pas du tout ce qu'il faut
faire actuellement il faut prendre un
autre système de chaudière puis vous
allez prendre conseil auprès d'un ami
qui veut dire non mais si vous changez
la chaudière et vous avez pas fait
l'isolation ça sert à rien parce que
vous continuez à jouer au dessus et donc
oh là là c'est extrêmement difficile
donc pour ça moi j'avais recommandé dans
un rapport sur l'innovation thermique de
développer l'accompagnement
l'accompagnement c'est vous avez
quelqu'un qui vient déjà vous faire un
diagnostic un diagnostic fiable sur ce
qu'il faut faire dans votre maison dans
votre appartement qui ensuite vous met
en place un plan de financement et va
vous dire pour le reste à charge et vous
savez que vous avez droit à tel
subventions vous savez que vous avez
droit à ma prime rénove puis aussi qui
va vous suivre dans les travaux et je
pense qu'il y a que en massifiant cet
accompagnement dans la rénovation qu'on
va arriver à régler ce problème de la
rénovation des des logements et pour
relancer la construction de logements
neufs des professionnels de l'immobilier
qui ont tiré boule rouge sur le plan du
gouvernement alors ils ont tiré à boulet
rouge sur le plan du gouvernement mais
il va falloir sans doute qu'on réinvente
ce secteur là moi je suis frappé je vous
dis en voyant beaucoup les élus vous
savez la quand on dirige la banque des
territoires on est toute la semaine dans
les territoires et on est toute la
semaine au contact des élus et je vois
bien que l'idée
d'artificialiser les sols c'est terminé
donc il va falloir réinventer la ville
différemment il va falloir reconstruire
la ville sur la ville donc ça veut dire
parfois transformer des bâtiments qui
étaient des bâtiments de bureau en
logement il va falloir aussi faire
parfois des surés des surélévation de
technologiquement c'est possible et vous
le faites sans transformer Rennes ou
Nantes en Singapour Hong Kong vous
rajoutez juste un étage il va falloir
aussi réaménager certains quartiers de
ville je pense par exemple à aux entrées
de ville vous voyez les entrées de ville
ou vous avez des grandes surfaces
et puis des parkings et ces entrées de
ville d'abord esthétiquement elles sont
pas toujours très réussies mais ensuite
d'un point de vue économique
e-commercial ça décline un petit peu
parce que le commerce électronique se
développe et puis la ville c'était
tendue les a rattrapés bah ça c'est des
terrains sur lesquels vous pouvez
remettre des logements reconfigurer
parce que ça a déjà été artificialisé
vous avez déjà la voirie vous avez déjà
l'eau vous avez déjà l'électricité et
vous pouvez à ce moment-là laisser
tomber ces cages à chaussures qui sont
parfois pas esthétiquement et qui ne
vont pas bien pour réinventer des
quartiers de ville c'est ce qu'on fait
par exemple avec CDC habitat puis un
promoteur immobilier qui s'appelle frais
et on a déjà des entrées de villes sur
lesquels on retravaille qu'est-ce que la
banque du territoire peut faire de plus
que ce qu'elle fait aujourd'hui pour
apporter pardon pour le mot sapiens à
l'édifice en matière de logement
abordable au-delà de ce qui est fait sur
le logement social et au-delà du fait de
racheter encore une fois des logements
neufs aux promoteurs qui sont en
difficulté ce que c'est des si habitats
va faire exactement alors au-delà de ça
il y a la question de l'Ingénierie et du
Conseil et
la banque des territoires c'est une
grande banque qui finance chaque année
12 milliards de près au logement social
et collectivité locale qui investit
aussi qui investit dans des foncières à
peu près 2 milliards mais c'est aussi
une banque qui travaille beaucoup ce
qu'on appelle l'ingénierie le Conseil
par exemple on l'a fait pour les 222 à
ville moyenne vous savez l'opération
coeur de ville je parle de Vesoul de
Vierzon de Colmar
de Chateaubriand de Dunkerque sur
lesquels on avait des coeurs de ville
qui
parce que Angoulême c'est pas Vierzon
Vesoul c'est pas Dole c'est pas un non
plus avec des projets qu'on a construit
sur la durée sur le long terme et ça
c'est des projets très intéressants on
rentre maintenant dans le projet action
coeur de ville 2 qui est le deuxième
mandat des mères et dans lesquels
qu'est-ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui on voit
l'immobilier qui reprend donc dans ces
villes là les Français retrouvés le goût
des villes moyennes on voit la la
vacance commerciale baissée c'est à dire
que les magasins reviennent mais c'est
plus les mêmes magasins qu'avant c'est
pas forcément des magasins de textile
c'est magasin qui sont plutôt résistants
au commerce électronique et et ça ce
sont des solutions que la banque des
territoires était plutôt plutôt bonne à
promouvoir Olivier si cher n'a pas
évoqué parce que vous parlez des mères
la question des de la difficulté c'est
ce que disent les professionnels de
l'immobilier à obtenir des permis de
construire il y a quand même ça encore
une fois est-ce qu'il y a c'est pas
aussi ça le fond du sujet sur le foncier
encore une fois en France alors il y a
effectivement un problème de de de
fonciers et d'obtention des permis de
construire alors
c'est pas nouveau et pardon et c'est pas
nouveau et c'est pas nouveau c'est pas
nouveau en revanche ce qui est nouveau
c'est que le zéro artificialisation
créer une contrainte extrêmement forte
auprès des mers qui fait qu'il va
falloir
identifier avec beaucoup plus de
précision le véritable foncier
disponible qui existe chez mer et quand
on commence à travailler avec les maires
de façon précise mais sous contrainte on
retrouve du foncier disponible on va
s'apercevoir que vous avez un délaissé
de la SNCF près de la gare qu'on
pourrait utiliser on va s'apercevoir que
vous avez un garage abandonné qu'on a
laissé tomber parce que en fait il est
pollué qu'on pourrait très bien
dépolluer après tout on va s'apercevoir
que dans l'entrée de ville il y a des
parkings qui ont été surdimensionnés sur
lesquels on pourrait retravailler
j'étais
il y a deux semaines à Mulhouse à
Mulhouse il y a une très grande friche
industrielle qui s'appelle la friche DMC
je sais pas si DMC ça vous rappelle
quelque chose non t'es entreprises
textile star des années 50 donc qui
laisse j'étais un peu petit à l'époque
exactement exactement et ça n'existe
plus et ça a des périodes et ça a laissé
12 hectares en plein cœur de la ville
d'une friche industrielle bon avec la
mer Michel Lutz on a un projet dans
lequel il y aura une partie
réindustrialisation mais il y aura aussi
une partie logement donc de la
contrainte va naître
une riz en identification du foncier
qu'on a un peu laissé tomber en disant
ça c'est la SNCF ça va être compliqué de
discuter avec la SNCF ça c'est pollué ça
va coûter cher de dépolluer ça c'est des
anciennes friches industrielles est-ce
qu'on a vraiment quelque chose à faire
on va le réinventer on va le
retravailler et moi je suis je fais
confiance au maire pour retrouver des
solutions donc le logement grande cause
nationale pour les prochaines années
parce qu'effectivement on risque une
crise sociétale si les Français
n'arrivent pas à se parviennent plus à
se loger dignement est correctement on
est d'accord là-dessus on est d'accord
bon dans les territoires il y a aussi le
déploiement du réseau de fibre optique
que vous menez à très haut débit dans
les territoires ruraux c'est ainsi aussi
qu'on peut réduire la fracture numérique
et le désenclavement de certains
territoires absolument on en parle
peut-être pas assez d'ailleurs de ça
alors on en parle pas assez parce qu'on
restait c'est une c'est un problème qui
est en passe d'être résolu quand je suis
arrivé vous savez moi je viens de
Digital j'ai dit j'ai Wanadoo avant donc
le Digital est important et je pense que
c'était la première des fractures
territoriales c'est soit vous êtes
connecté soit vous n'êtes pas c'est 0,1
informatique c'est assez clair c'est
binaire et
quand je suis arrivé on aille fixé comme
objectif à la banque des territoires un
outil territoire plus connecté et de
raccorder 10 millions de foyers en zone
rurale au débit je parle pas de l'ADSL
je vous parle de la fibre optique à date
on est à 8 millions de fois aux zones
blanches rurales zone rurale vous savez
c'est défini réglementairement vous avez
la zone dense
devenir et se développer et il y aura
pas de nouvelles industrie sans fibre
optique et donc à ce moment-là vous avez
le préalable nécessaire à tout un
développement un projet de développement
de territoire en tout cas c'est une
fierté pour vous de se dire que on voit
l'utilité encore une fois au quotidien
pour les Français concrètement
absolument il y a des réalisations la
fibre optique on en parle pas mais quand
on se compare quand vous allez en
Allemagne quand vous allez même en
Belgique ou en Italie en Espagne cette
idée d'avoir une couverture à 99% je ne
vous pas le 100% vous allez me trouver
sans doute des villages dans les Alpes
ou dans le Massif central ou le
raccordement la film n'est pas prévu
mais à 99% c'est assez unique en Europe
et moi je pense que ça va faire une
grosse grosse différence pour notre pays
pendant les territoires où ça avance
bien ou c'est quasiment terminé ou soit
il y a du retard justement où le job
n'est pas terminé alors
Nord-Pas-de-Calais tout couvert grand
est tout couvert depuis Thomas donc
lameuse l'aube les Ardennes la Mayenne
la Sarthe les endroits où un petit peu
en retard c'est la Bretagne on travaille
d'arrache-pied pour couvrir la Bretagne
et puis des parties du Massif Central
lot Aveyron Lozère bon sans vous quand
ils s'en vont lui si je fais sans la
banque des territoires qu'est-ce qui
n'aurait pas vu le jour sur le
territoire dans les actions que vous
menez donc il y a le raccordement nous
on s'est donné quatre axes au début
avant qu'il était toi territoire plus
connecté j'ai envie de dire le
raccordement très haut débit c'est
véritablement fait ce sera derrière nous
à raison 2025 c'est-à-dire demain
ensuite on avait dit des territoires
plus attractifs donc on a tous ce
programme cœur de ville et là on voit
bien alors les villes ne sont pas
homogènes mais qui a eu un véritable
retour des villes moyennes qui est très
important souvenez-vous un moment la
ville moyenne c'était un peu la ville
d'où partait le mouvement des gilets
jaunes l'endroit où on était délaissé où
il se passait rien aujourd'hui les
Français ont retrouvé l'appétit de la
ville moyenne de la taille humaine la
crise sanitaire est passée par là et
elle a eu un impact très positif
il y a la question des territoires plus
verts qui est la grande affaire de notre
nouveau mandat d'arriver vraiment à
piloter cette transformation écologique
alors là ce que l'on fait
c'est par exemple les infrastructures de
recherche de véhicules électriques toute
la je sais que vous recevez vous avez eu
Xena il y a pas tellement longtemps donc
automobile est en train de passer à
l'électrique on n'est pas en avant sur
le bandes de recharge c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire exactement et donc
comme on n'est pas en avance a décidé de
s'en occuper et de déployer les bandes
de recherche véhicule électrique on a
déjà déployé 100000 et là l'objectif
d'en déployer 300 000 de plus à quelle
raison alors vraiment à l'horizon de
notre plan qui est donc sur 2023 2028 ce
qui nous permettra dans leur dans la
moyenne européenne sur sur les rails en
matière des taux d'équipements de bornes
parce que la France est un grand pays
très très très vaste c'est plus facile
si vous voulez équiper en bain de
recherche wikile électrique le
Luxembourg les Pays-Bas parce que la
France à la suite je sais pas si les
montagnes oui c'est que ça n'aide pas
bon puisqu'on parle des villes vertes il
y a la question de des énergies
renouvelables manifestement la France ne
respectera pas son objectif de
production d'électricité renouvelable
fin 2023 et encore moins celui de 2028
est-ce que sur le solaire sur l'éolien
on va pas assez vite même si des lois
ont été votées que faire de plus et
comment vous intervenez alors on
intervient de façon massive parce que on
représente 20% de la capacité
additionnelle d'énergie nouvelle
renouvelable chaque année c'est à dire
que vous avez les grands acteurs vous
avez les total vous avez les enj et puis
nous nous finançons à un certain nombre
d'acteurs indépendants des entreprises
s'appelle énergie qui s'appelle jp2e qui
sont des développeurs d'énergie solaire
j'ai envie de dire sur le solaire je
trouve qu'on est plutôt en train de
rattraper le retard là où on a pris
énormément de retard c'est l'éolien
c'est l'éolien et notamment l'éolien
offshore
on est très engagé dans l'éolien
offshore mais force est de constater que
là où des états comme le Danemark ou
comme la Suède sont-elles très très vite
l'Angleterre aussi ou l'Angleterre tout
à fait nous on a pris beaucoup de retard
alors l'environnement législatif a
changé pour aller plus vite mais
dans ce domaine le retard pris ne se
rattrapera pas donc
ce qui n'a pas été investi la date pèse
parce que
est-ce qu'on accélère suffisamment lié
si chez elle
je pense que il faudra voir si les
effets de la loi vont véritablement se
traduire dans toutes les procédures
administratives et trop longue toutes
les prochaines essenti Toulon ici on
arrivera à faire ce qui est difficile en
fait c'est d'avoir une approche
séquentielle c'est à dire que vous avez
tel autorisation qui vous permet d'avoir
tel autorisation qui vont venir tel
autorisation ce qu'on essaye de faire
dans le nouvel environnement législatif
c'est de paralléliser de façon à étant
en capacité d'installer ces nouvelles
éoliennes le plus rapidement possible
bon il faut qu'on parle de l'industrie
et entre tout ça est lié l'industrie
verte est pas seulement on peut déprimer
quand on voit le déficit commercial de
la France abyssale historique sur 2022
160 milliards et des brouettes et en
même temps depuis 2017 300 nouveaux
sites industriels sont sortis de terre
90 000 emplois ont été créés dans
l'industrie alors que 2 millions ayant
été détruits en 40 ans et ce que la
malédiction de la désindustrialisation
française est-ce qu'elle est derrière
nous ou pas est-ce qu'un renouveau
industriel qui est en marché ce qu'on a
touché le fond de la piscine ce qu'on en
est aujourd'hui moi je suis convaincu
qu'on a touché le fond de la piscine et
on le voit à travers le sol de l'usine
aujourd'hui on crée plus d'usine qu'on
en détruit et à la banque des
territoires est très présente nous dans
le nouveau plan de réindustrialisation
on a prévu d'investir un milliard alors
un milliard dans l'équipement industriel
des fonctions du ciel on investit pas au
capital des entreprises ça c'est le rôle
de notre cousine BPI France et qui elle
s'occupe des entrepreneurs et vous savez
vous posez pas une usine comme vous
posez votre nappe de pique-nique c'est
un peu compliqué et donc il faut avoir
du foncier du foncier raccordé raccordé
au débit on en a parlé mais de plus en
plus la vie dit c'est les usines vertes
les
industriels sont soucieux d'avoir une
énergie verte raccordable donc
qui soit certifié verte ils ont besoin
de grosses plateformes logistiques pour
pouvoir
avoir des intrants et les sortir et donc
moi je vois un grand mouvement de
développement industriel avec de très
grandes usines on est présent sur les
gigafactory on crée on va financer les
giga Factory de Vercors à Dunkerque
quand il va financer
dans les hauts de France dans les
Hauts-de-France on va financer celle
d'une vision à Douai donc ça ce sont de
très très grosses usines à plus d'un
milliard on finance aussi une moyenne
d'usine par exemple je sais pas si vous
dit quelque chose d'insectes Amiens
exactement donc là dans financier
l'usine et puis aussi il faut encore une
secte de la nourriture de la protéine
pour le bétail à partir de scarabées
le scarabée on le broie et ses
alimentations pour le bétail qui se
substitue aux alimentations de type soja
qu'on importe de d'Amérique latine et
vous voyez toutes ces toutes ces
industries dont je vous parle à une
vision dans les batteries électriques
insectes dans l'immatisation sociale
c'est du industrie verte c'est l'instru
verte c'est l'industrie vert on a des
places à prendre parce qu'on sait que
sur les sur les panneaux solaires pardon
le marché est en Chine sur les
semi-conducteurs même s'il y a des
investissements en France globalement
ils sont ailleurs voilà qui est sur quoi
on peut se position
et donc sur fabriquer des réservoirs
hydrogène c'est la banque des
territoires qui a financé
l'usine de Fortia puisque
se situe dans le Doubs qui était une
usine qui devait partir au départ en
Pologne et on a convaincu Forcia de
l'installer dans ce bassin vous savez
qu'il y a une grande tradition
automobile on est sur Peugeot Sochaux
Mulhouse et donc c'est là où on va
fabriquer l'hydrogène et on est
partenaire par exemple une entreprise
qui s'appelle Life qui fait de
l'hydrogène à partir de l'eau de mer sur
donc parce qu'il faut beaucoup d'eau
pour faire de l'hydrogène donc je vois
que dans l'hydrogène on a été partenaire
aussi de makphy enfin je pouvais c’était
beaucoup d'entreprises et des
écosystèmes régionaux incroyablement
mimiques autour de l'hydrogène en tout
cas pour l'instant ça ne se voit pas sur
le défi commercial français qui reste
dans leur vie historique abyssal voilà
mais en tout cas voilà on plante les
graines pour pour l'avenir et puis il y
a eu ce crédit d'impôt qui a été décidé
en tout cas pas encore voté par le par
le gouvernement crédit d'impôt pour
l'industrie verte panneau solaire
éolienne batterie électrique pompe à
chaleur compris j'en ai chiffre pardon
entre 20 et 45 % des montants qui sont
investis et c'est une arme
anti-américaine anti-inflation le fameux
plan de Joe Biden pour relocaliser sur
le sol américain même pour les boîtes
étrangères est-ce que cette arme
française est assez puissante elle sera
puissante que si elle est qualifiée dans
une dimension européenne je pense que
face aux Américains la bonne réponse est
toujours européenne les raisons de le
signer une fashion réduction actes est
un arme de relocalisation massive et
quelque part une forme de
protectionnisme vont bénéficier les
entreprises françaises qui iront sur le
sol américain
et donc la réponse elle peut être que
européenne alors nous on le voit vous
savez manque des territoires la Caisse
des Dépôts elle a des homologues il y a
la kfv en Allemagne il y a la tchédity
en Italie et on partage un petit peu les
diagnostics que face à ça il faut une il
faut une réponse européenne qui soit son
naïveté comme souvent plus rapide aussi
bon il faut qu'on parle aussi de la
décarbonation de l'économie française
tout ça est lié évidemment on a appris
par le rapport de Jean Pisani Ferri que
il y aura un besoin d'investissement
supplémentaire de 66 milliards d'euros
par an ton prêt de la moitié qui viendra
de la puissance publique on se dit que
le coût quand même est pharaonique et on
se dit mais qui va payer la facture
est-ce qu'il faut accepter un supplément
de dette est-ce qu'il faut demander un
effort fiscal au plus élevé rien est
tranché mais les montants à venir sont
gigantesques oui mais ils sont ils sont
à notre portée quand on a fait le plan
de relance la Caisse des dépôts à
mobilisé 28 milliards sur le plan de
relance en soutien au logement on
soutient l'industrie touristique on
soutient au commerce de proximité là
sur la base de du rapport Pisani
ferrique qui a été membre de la
commission de surveillance de la Caisse
des Dépôts on voit bien que la Caisse
des Dépôts aura un rôle à jouer qui sera
ni de la fiscalité puisque comme on l'a
rappelé au début de notre entretien
c'est l'épargne des français qu'on vient
au travail
ni de la subvention mais qui pourrait
être de l'investissement parce que la
conviction que j'ai c'est que dans le
domaine des énergies nouvelles
renouvelables ce sont des modèles
rentables dans le domaine de la
décarbonation des transports ce sont des
modèles rentables ou en prêt auprès des
collectivités locales pour par exemple
rénover les écoles c'est le grand
programme qu'on a lancé qui s'appelle
indurénov qui a vocation rénover 10 000
écoles et qu'on le fera en prêt et là
vous savez les collectivités locales
elles ont une vraie capacité
d'endettement autant l'État français est
très endetté et on a un rapport de dette
publique sur pipe qui est élevé autant
de plupart des collectivités locales
elles sont très très bien gérées et
elles traînent de plus en plus
conscience qu'elles ont ce que j'appelle
une dette écologique et que on peut
avoir une dette financière très très
basse et de se dire la durée moyenne
d'endettement des collectivités le cale
c'est 5 ans mais à quoi ça sert d'être
endetté sur cinq ans si j'ai des réseaux
d'eau qui fuient à 50% et si j'ai des
écoles qui sont des passoires thermiques
et donc je vois de plus en plus des élus
qui sont contents de le ratio financier
et qui ont plutôt une très très bonne
gestion se dire oui mais j'ai quand même
des infrastructures qui va falloir que
je j'adapte au changement climatique et
ça peut être des réseaux d'eau on en a
beaucoup parlé à travers le haut on ne
peut plus gaspiller l'eau donc quand
vous avez des réseaux qui fuient c'est
juste inacceptable donc il faut les
rénover il faut aussi rénover les
bâtiments publics d'un point de vue
thermique parce que ils ont eu des mais
à quel argent avec quel argent avec
l'argent des Français sur le livret A on
a des collectes records plus de 40
milliards depuis début de l'année et cet
argent les Français je pense attendent
que la banque des territoires le mette
au travail pour la transformation
écologique de notre pays c'est devenu
notre raison d'être et c'est devenu
véritablement notre première mission bon
avant de se quitter on parle de plus en
plus de ces Français qui quittent leur
job pour en trouver un autre qui donne
du sens à leur engagement professionnel
vous venez pas ce problème là en tant
que patron de la banque des territoires
non on a la ligne entre une énorme
satisfaction c'est énorme satisfaction
pour moi il y a beaucoup de candidatures
les gens trouvent que il y a un sens à
ce qu'on fait que ce soit sur notre
mission pour le logement social que ce
soit sur notre mission sur la
transformation écologique
on essaye d'être le plus vertueux
possible on est les premiers à avoir mis
l'évaluation financière au même rang que
l'évaluation extra-financière dans tous
les dossiers qu'on regarde il y a une
note financière habituelle le calcul du
tri et puis le rendement
internement interne et puis une note
extra-financière on va voir quel est le
bilan carbone quel est le bilan sur la
biodiversité quels sont les impacts sur
la gouvernance sur l'emploi qui fait
qu'on a des des projets qui sont assez
magnifiques il y en a un qui qui est
sympathique assez connu qui est le
village olympique le village des
athlètes oui on va livrer pour héberger
les athlètes et qui après sera
transformé en logement avec lesquels il
y aura des logements étudiants du
logement libre des logements sociaux et
même un foyer émigré allez merci pour
cette entretien ici chez le Merci à VOUS
directeurs de la banque des territoires
merci beaucoup allez libre-échange c'est
à voir ou revoir sur Public Sénat et il
y a du replay bien sûr sur notre
nouvelle plateforme public sénat.fr à
bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]